if a back workout to you means training
your lats and traps then you may be
missing out on the transformative
potential of a truly powerful and mobile
spine
as they say you are as young as your
spine
not only can back complaints instantly
put an end to athletic careers
and normal daily activities but a weak
spine will also weaken every other
movement you perform
and the truth is that most people have
weak stiff spines
this is because we spend a huge amount
of time sitting with poor posture
when we do get up we're so out of
practice bending and lifting that we
move with bad biomechanics
or we head to the gym and attack these
vulnerable muscles with heavy explosive
movements that they are ill-prepared for
these sudden bouts of intense activity
shock and exhausted and already weakened
and inflexible spine
resulting in injury so how do we fix
this
the first key is to recognize that as
the back mechanic dr stuart mcgill is
keen to point out
back pain and injury is usually
cumulative rather than instantaneous
the moment you felt the pain was not the
moment the injury began that was merely
the
straw that quite literally broke the
camel's back the issue is long-term
degeneration
the spine itself was actually
surprisingly weak capable of
withstanding only around
20 pounds of force before collapsing
what provides the crucial stiffness
the separation and a stable base from
which all movement can occur
is the amazing strength of the muscle
surrounding it
the muscles of the spine work the entire
day to keep you upright
the erector spinae handle extension
backwards bending and work as
antagonists to the rectus abdominis the
six-pack
maintaining a delicate pool in either
direction to support an upright posture
just as the quadratus lumborum do on
either side
then there's the multifidus the
multifidus muscles are a group of short
deep bilateral muscles that are arranged
along the spine
these work in conjunction with the
rotators with an extra e
and were believed to be unimportant
until relatively recently demonstrating
once again just how little we really
know about the body
we now know that these muscles serve a
crucial role in stabilizing and
stiffening the spine
they contribute both to extension and to
lateral flexion and rotation
and contain fibers that are stiffer and
stronger than any other fibers in the
human body
these muscles act in an anticipatory
manner bracing the spine against other
movements in the body
to this end they contain an abnormally
high number of muscle spindles
thus providing proprioception the
problem is that they're so underused by
most of us
that we've deadened this awareness of
our posture contrary to popular belief
the transverse abdomini does not provide
local stability in the spine
but rather a global tension throughout
the core which is not to say it has no
benefit
the lats even play a role in spinal and
core stability as we discussed in a
previous video
these are the muscles we must train in
order to strengthen our spine and
therefore to make every single movement
more powerful and more stable
a good starting point is to train the
muscle endurance of these areas
especially as stabilizers seeing as
these muscles work throughout the day
when we're moving
and undergo unusual patterns of
activation when we're sitting they're
particularly vulnerable to injury
when it comes to explosive powerful
movements at the gym or when carrying
heavy things around the home
you might have powerful glutes and quads
to drive you through that squat
but if your spine is tired after a long
hard day or unresponsive due to hours of
sitting
then this is the weak link that is going
to snap one great exercise to counter
this issue
is bird dog which as a parent makes me
think of a mog book let me know in the
comments if you get what i'm talking
about
this movement involves getting onto all
fours and then extending one hand
forwards and the opposite leg backwards
this requires stabilization in the spine
training the multifidus muscles
you can hold this position for long
durations thereby gaining that much
needed mind muscle connection
and strength endurance to keep the spine
stable and protected
this is also where the beauty of many
so-called functional exercises
become apparent once again when you
perform a cable punch or one arm to
press you must brace the spine to
counteract the force
this is again how we punch and push in
real life not lying down as we do in a
bench press
lizard crawls and one-armed push-ups
have a similar benefit
although prone they challenge you to
brace into a variety of different
positions
and support structures preventing
rotation flexion etc
performed mindfully this also helps to
reawaken sensitivity of the spine
to train it to be aware of how we're
moving and to react and brace
accordingly
this is why i like to slow the lizard
crawl right down and move in all
directions in an unpredictable manner
one armed rowing movements are also
useful such as the bent dumbbell row
or one armed body weight rail with
rotation these have a stabilizing
element
while also challenging the spine under
heavy loads remember that you should be
easing into these movements if you
aren't used to them
easier variations exist for everything
from one-armed wall push-ups to bear
crawls
then there are carriers and farmers
walks these train muscle endurance and
stabilization in an upright position
helping the erector spinae to keep you
in good posture for long durations
this is useful seeing as it's how we're
supposed to use the spine in the first
place
if you can walk long distances holding
weights and maintain a strong neutral
spine
then you should have no problem blasting
out a few squats or carrying your kid to
the car
especially if you're using a unilateral
variation such as the suitcase carry
or perhaps a front-loaded carry train
this at the end of a workout not at the
start
fatiguing your core muscles this way
before attempting a deadlift is inviting
injury
running is another extremely useful tool
when running you should focus on keeping
your body in an upright position
this is actually why many people injure
themselves when attempting a 10k for the
first time
or similar they're simply unable to
maintain proper posture
when fatigued practice this by slowly
increasing your distance while
being mindful of your biomechanics we
can also actively train extension using
movements like the superman
of course this involves lying flat on
your face and then raising your hands
and legs effectively balancing out all
those situps and dragon flags
except here's where the controversy
comes in some experts like stuart
mcgill advise against the superman move
and others like the roman chair
stating that these place too much
compression on the spine he recommends
the bird dog as a replacement
though this doesn't offer much in the
way of anti-flexion and is really more
of an anti-rotation movement
i personally also perform the back
bridge which is a fantastic movement for
quickly restoring both shoulder mobility
and thoracic mobility this is a static
stretch so don't do it before the rest
of your training
i'm also partial to the hindu press up
or dive bomber which i think are great
movements for their ability to combine
both the pushing workout
and mobility training keep in mind that
both these and the back bridge place
compressive force on the spine
and thus also aren't recommended by
everyone the issue that the likes of
mcgill have here
is with long-term micro fractures that
can build up with extended use
don't use these at least to begin with
if you have any back complaints and
consider starting with the short bridge
on your shoulders
honestly though yogis and indian
wrestlers have been using movements like
these for decades with mostly good
things to show for it
but your mileage may vary so think about
what you want to achieve
listen to your body and proceed with
caution even more controversial is the
jefferson curl which dr stew also does
not love
he believes it's useful for sport
specific training as a gymnast
but not for the general population this
movement is key in gymnastic strength
training though
and is heavily promoted by the likes of
coach summers the movement is akin to a
straight-legged deficit deadlift
meaning that you're standing on a
slightly raised platform but here the
aim is to allow flexion in the spine and
to imagine
each vertebrae unfurling as you move
through your complete range of motion
keeping the chin tucked the entire time
you then contract the glutes before
gradually reversing the movement back
upwards
as you can probably guess use a very
light weight for this one so should you
use jefferson curls
i would say that if you have any history
of back pain then certainly approach
with extreme caution
personally i believe that strengthening
muscles through our entire ranges of
motion can only be a good thing
but it also depends on individual
lifestyles and goals and there are safer
alternatives that we'll get to in a
moment
but you see we can't really talk about
extension without also discussing
thoracic mobility
because while the lumbar spine should be
very stiff to reduce degradation the
middle of the spine the thoracic spine
should have decent mobility for twisting
and bending in both directions
while many of us are afraid to bend our
spines especially under load
the truth is that the spine is clearly
designed to move this way
try moving your body without bending or
twisting the spine at all and you'll
find you are significantly less agile
and functional
a little flexion in the spine is almost
inevitable in daily life during
movements like picking up a child
out of a cart or unloading the
dishwasher especially for untrained
individuals
then there are racket sports and
countless other activities that require
rapid extension and twisting as part of
the stretch shortening cycle and guess
what if you have a stiff thoracic spine
then it's the lumbar spine that's going
to bend instead
but what can we use to regain some
mobility here that isn't quite so
controversial
this is where more animal movement type
training can really shine again
the crab walk and tabletop movements for
example will gradually increase mobility
in the spine
whilst also serving as a beneficial
anti-flexion movement
i'm also a big fan of the crab reach
this movement also provides some
thoracic rotation which you can likewise
get from the windmill
another option recommended by mcgill is
cat camel
here you rest on all fours and simply
move the spine from an arched position
to a concave one
so that's a heck of a lot of information
and much of it is contradictory
so what do i actually recommend you do
if you want to develop better spine
mobility strength and resilience
my recommendation is to start by adding
stability exercises in all planes of
motion
any combination of the following will do
great pilot press
bird dog dragon flag land push up ab
roll out
one arm standing cable row cable punches
suitcase carry one arm push-up
lizard crawls and goblet or zercher
front carry this is fairly
uncontroversial and should provide
performance benefits and prehab
throwing some endurance tasks like
running and skipping being mindful to
keep the back upright at all times
and you've got a great recipe for a
strong and stable back you should also
strengthen the hamstrings in the glute
using movements like the glute bridge to
take
pressure off the spine training thoracic
extension rotation and mobility with
tabletop
crab walks cat camel windmill and the
bridge reachover
is also advisable but if you're after
next level mobility and control you can
also try the backbridge jefferson curl
or hindu push-up
but be aware of the caution surrounding
these exercises and use at your own risk
of course this isn't to undermine the
importance of deadlifts
and kettlebell swings and other more
conventional ways of training your lower
back
and also of course all of those core
exercises whether it's v-ups or hollow
bodies
but the point is that this isn't enough
on its own and there's lots more you can
do to supplement
that training if you want to give
yourself a more resilient and performant
spine
if you have any back complaints at all
then see a professional there's no
advice you can get from the internet
that will be particularly tailored to
your specific injury and biomechanics
and without being seen by an expert any
exercise regime may make matters worse
or might overlook a serious issue
keep in mind that nothing is set in
stone and we're still learning as you
can see here the experts are pretty much
unanimously
in disagreement with each other even
seemingly simple assumptions such as the
importance of the s curvature of the
spine have been challenged author esther
gokhale is among those who believe that
the natural position of the spine
should actually be more akin to a j
observations of young children
indigenous tribes and historic
sculptures all seem to support this
notion
compelling those circumstantial evidence
the danger i believe is to get too wed
to the advice of any one expert to the
point of ignoring contradictory
information
gently integrate ideas from every source
and see what works for you
this should be a good starting point for
most people and whatever you do is a
million times better than doing nothing
at all
and while all this disagreement might be
discouraging there is a silver lining
it means that if you've been trying to
fix a back complaint for years
there might still be someone out there
with a different approach that works for
you
or perhaps there's a new discovery just
around the corner that can help if you
have back pain then it has to have a
cause
the point is that there's almost always
a solution out there which probably
involves some kind of movement
your mission is to find the right person
with the right options for you
so don't give up hope you found this
video useful interesting guys if you did
then please leave a like and share
around
it helps me out immensely subscribe if
you want to see more like this
and if you like the idea of training for
true functional performance you can use
in the real world and
focusing on much more than just a few
lifts or cardio and you'll probably
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training there i go
into great detail discussing how
different forms of training can improve
the mind and body and then combine all
this into a single training program
that should help to improve your
performance and health across the board
there's a link to that in description
down below and there's a big discount on
right now whilst we're all stuck in
lockdown
whatever the case thank you so much for
watching this one and i'll see you next
time
thanks for watching and bye for now